[Música]
cuántos de aquí ya no cumplimos los 35
años
vale me siento un poquito más
confortable siento las personas que sois
de fuera porque a lo mejor esta imagen
nos dice nada pero hace ya bastantes
años más de 35 yo soy el pequeño de seis
hermanos y había una ceremonia en los
domingos que a mí me parecía fascinante
que era acompañar a mi padre a comprar
el periódico y esperar que en su
omnipotente y potente sabiduría me
deslizará un mortadelo que era la
lectura de toda la semana os voy a poner
un poquito en contexto los que no habéis
vivido esa época había sólo dos canales
de televisión no había internet por
supuesto se puede vivir sin internet y
hay algunos ejemplos brillantes de ello
porque traigo aquí esto había una parte
de esta sección de esta revista que
a mí me llamaba muchísimo la atención y
era la parte de correspondencia
eran personas que compraban como yo la
revista y que ponían anuncios diciendo
susana carretero quiero contactar con
chicos de 14 a 18 años para hablar de
deportes y daba pues avenida tenor fleta
está en zaragoza y daba la dirección y
lo que estaba buscando era abrir su
círculo de amistades
esto os podéis imaginar que era todo un
proceso escribe una carta manda la carta
que la revista decida publicarlo esperar
a que alguien lo vea y volver cómo se
resuelve eso ahora
ahora
los mismos niños de esa misma edad que
tienen las mismas necesidades no nos
engañemos que tienen exactamente las
mismas necesidades quieren dar
visibilidad a lo que hacen quieren
contactar con otros chavales más allá de
lo que es su círculo habitual pues
utilizan instagram apostarán pero puede
ser cualquier caso en este caso dice oye
tengo 14 años no me juzgues empieza bien
y voy a mostraros lo que yo hago de tal
manera que él se abre al mundo que es lo
que ha pasado entre una imagen y la otra
lo que ha pasado lógicamente es aparte
de años pues un montón de aventuras
familiares que he tenido pues desarrolla
mi propia familia de seres queridos por
todas las partes lo que he podido es
vivir en primera persona lo que ha sido
la transformación digital entre estas
dos imágenes lo que hay es un inicio que
era
tuve la suerte de participar en la
primera de las empresas más pioneras y
que vendieron más ordenadores en españa
si diego la marca no es trascendente
porque es que ya ha desaparecido y era
la número uno y eso me hizo el mejor
amigo del hombre sabéis cuál es el mejor
amigo del hombre el culpable y entonces
será por tu culpa mi hijo no se separa
del ordenador pero ahí no pasó no quedó
la cosa sino que tuve la suerte de
participar en un proyecto de los
primeros portales de internet que ahora
ya simplemente decir portal internet ya
es anacrónico no a nadie sabe lo que es
un portal de internet
bueno pues tuve la suerte de participar
ahí y volví a ser el mejor amigo del
hombre por culpa tuya tú mi hijo no se
separa de internet
y la tercera ya fue la hecatombe ya fue
cuando entré en la parte de telefonía
móvil 3g que iba a ser aquello y lo ha
sido y va a ser la revolución y de nuevo
ya si no había si había sido no era
suficiente con el ordenador y el
internet es que soy el culpable de que
haya móviles en todos los lados aparte
de ser el culpable lo que me ha
permitido está en una visión de cómo
está influenciando estos cambios
tecnológicos en la sociedad porque no es
que fuera más listo sino que simplemente
tenía acceso a más información entonces
yo era capaz de decir dentro de poco
compraremos todos las entradas del cine
con el ordenador y ahora queda entonces
un familiar mío me decía pero tú de qué
vas o sea tú sabes lo que es encender el
ordenador conectarte a internet comprar
aquí si es más fácil ir al cine pero lo
estábamos viendo con una perspectiva que
todo aquello era muy elaborado
que aparte de mi vida personal que ha
pasado en esos dos en esos dos
intervalos pues en esos dos intervalos
ha habido una cosa que lo ha
revolucionado absolutamente todo y le da
una velocidad sin precedentes
es la aparición de los smartphones yo
cuando hablas con gente más joven y les
dices que el smartphone no existía antes
del 2007 no se lo pueden creer cuando
les dices que cosas como instagram
facebook whatsapp no existían eran
conceptos que se habían desarrollado de
otra manera pero que no existían y lo
que nos ha traído el smartphone han sido
tres cosas que han sido de una
contundencia y de una violencia tremenda
y que está relacionado con lo que
hablábamos también los chicos jóvenes
una es la escala cualquier cosa que yo
hago tiene una escala planetaria antes
la persona que subía una información
nada al al ante veo mortadelo que
ocurría pues es que se circunscribe a la
gente que leyes a esa prensa y que
además tenía algún interés con lo cual y
era ámbito de españa ahora mismo el niño
que sube unas imágenes está accediendo
al mundo la segunda es la inmediatez
no estábamos habituados todas las casi
todas las comunicaciones eran asíncronas
incluso cuando llamadas por teléfono hoy
está a pepito no no está si tenemos que
volver a esperar y en algunas familias
grandes y numerosas como yo que eran
seis tenías que esperar el turno porque
también había otros llamando a sus
pepitos y aquello era era harto difícil
y entonces esto es inmediato es de
escala planetaria inmediato y la otra es
que es lo que hacemos todos antes de
cerrar los ojos para dormir miramos el
último vistazo al móvil qué es lo que
hacemos nada más despertar jos mirar el
móvil como si por la noche hubiese
pasado algo que necesita nuestra
atención e inmediata de hecho creo que
hay una estadística que el 60% de todos
nosotros miramos el móvil antes de poner
un pie en el suelo os imagináis sea que
ya en la cama ya agarramos el móvil y
miramos es una necesidad tremenda
esos tres fenómenos lo que han
configurado es
una identidad digital nosotros no ya no
solo nos definimos por lo que somos como
vestimos las conversaciones los idiomas
que hablamos sino por lo que tenemos en
el móvil si yo ahora cualquiera de
vosotros os digo me dejas tu móvil que
lo voy a usar durante todo el día me das
tus claves es yo creo que es la ofensa
más grande que puedes hacer a alguien
pero es más si yo te digo bueno de fin
de mente como eres
cuéntame oye tú como eres seguramente
que no eres capaz de definir te también
como lo hace tu móvil de ti o sea yo con
un móvil sé dónde has estado de
vacaciones y qué tiendas son las que más
te gustan qué música te gusta más en fin
qué lecturas tienes todo todo y entonces
nos ha creado una identidad digital y
esa identidad digital no somos del todo
propietarios porque la estamos
compartiendo con otros elementos que nos
están dando acceso a esas herramientas
entonces de repente aparece aquí un
individuo
con superpoderes inmediatez y
omnipresente permanentemente conectado y
además con un nivel de conocimiento de
su de su ser mayor que el que somos
capaces de contar nosotros como no va a
tener esto impacto en los negocios en la
administración pública en la educación
osea imaginaros todos nosotros que hemos
evolucionado los que venimos de la época
de mortadelo y los que habéis nacido
después de mortadelo con total
naturalidad estamos poniendo un nivel de
exigencia a todo lo que hacemos a las
empresas a las universidades que se
corresponden con la inmediatez la
permanente conexión con compartir cada
momento y si no lo compartes además
estás con cierta ansiedad el otro día
leí un tweet lo tengo que decir porque
es que me pareció magistral se tenía
tanto hambre que no me dio tiempo ni
hacer la foto es la gente ya hace la
foto del plato y luego dice voy a
comerme una los macarrones maravillosos
pues este tipo lo simple horizon 2 tenía
tanto hambre que no me da tiempo ni a
compartir la foto
bueno pues ese es ese fenómeno dicho en
positivo con una broma como la de nuevos
macarrones que ocurre cuando tú no estás
contento con unas líneas aéreas el
famoso caso del chico que lleva una
guitarra no lo dejaron hizo una canción
aquello se viralizó y las líneas aéreas
no sabían cómo gestionar esa reclamación
era un
un torpedo a su a su forma de gestionar
las las reclamaciones
y las empresas están un poquito
desbordados por no decir muy desbordadas
estamos muy desbordadas con este este
fenómeno oye qué es lo que estamos
proponemos para abordar esto de una
forma ordenada
joel
[Música]
en super cliente que tiene estás
y superpoderes no tiene nada que no
podamos acotar en tres fases una empresa
al final no deja de ser
un grupo de gente que tiene un propósito
que definen los procesos y utiliza unas
herramientas nosotros lo que siempre
pedimos a las empresas cuando deciden
abordar un proceso un proyecto de
transformación y cambiar la experiencia
en las tiendas son los edificios no
vamos más allá de eso preguntar el para
qué y luego ya trabajaremos el como oye
vamos a ver qué proceso tienes oye qué
objetivo tiene ese proceso hace falta
mantenerlo o lo quito y si lo mantengo
qué herramientas puedo tener para
modificarlo con las herramientas lo
mismo hoy vamos a pensar qué
herramientas no nos dejemos llevar no es
que mis empleados tienen que llevar una
tablet pero porque cuál es el propósito
vamos a pensar en que le va a ayudar y
por supuesto las personas si tú no
embarcas a las personas en esa aventura
olvidaros no hay proyecto de
transformación o sea el verdadero motor
de las transformaciones somos todos
nosotros no tengamos ninguna duda da
igual que sea en esta época o en la
época preindustrial
un caso y os pongo un caso de que
técnicamente es posible además que lo
hemos desarrollado después de varios
meses de trabajo con una cuenta lo que
hicimos fue analizar todo el proceso de
compra y lo que dijimos es porque tengo
que inicializar el proceso de compra
online o en la tienda cuando yo empiezo
en online porque no puedo ir a la tienda
y seguir comprando y todo eso nos de
llegó a pensar cómo podían escanear los
productos como esos productos podrían
aparecer en los probadores como yo en
los probadores encontraba de forma
mágica no era mágica un empleado te lo
llevaba los productos que tú has elegido
te los probabas si querías otra talla
pedías otra talla y podías luego elegir
quiero que me lo lleves a casa o quiero
comprarlo y llevármelo si decías me lo
llevo a casa rellena vas un sencillo
formulario que es como ya eres cliente
sólo tienes que poner tu código de
acceso y sí
quería salir de la tienda como ya lo
habías pagado el sistema sabía que tú ya
habías pagado y podría salir sin pasar
por caja esto técnicamente es posible la
pregunta que nos hacemos es por qué no
se hace más y ahí vienen los procesos
las herramientas y las personas las
empresas nos sigue costando muchísimo
abordar los cambios sabéis cuál es el
primer motivo de cierre de empresas no
es la macroeconomía no es el cambio
climático es una frase que es siempre se
hizo así yo eso me parece que es lo que
más destruye lo que más destruye en
todos los ámbitos hasta que no nos dé
desactivemos esa frase hasta que no
pensemos que se pueden hacer las cosas
de otra manera que tenemos que usar
otras herramientas que tenemos que
definir otros procesos y que tenemos que
utilizar a todas las personas que
participaron en el éxito de lo que nos
llevó a la empresa hasta allí porque no
podemos dejar a nadie atrás y todo el
mundo tiene mucho que aportar hasta que
no entendamos que esto no va de
tecnología esto
de personas y de valores saber qué cosas
voy a hacer con la información que
obtengo no solo para quedarme con el
lucro sino también para respetar a esa
persona darle mejor servicio saber qué
distinguir cuando son noticias de lo que
son genios la tecnología sin valores y
sin personas de verdad no tiene ningún
valor
ya para cerrar solo deciros compartir
con vosotros un pensamiento la
tecnología muchas veces yo lo oigo en
gente más joven está muy asociado a dos
conceptos y son dos conceptos que iñaki
gabilondo dijo que después de muchos
años había llegado a la certeza de que
eran totalmente falsos y por lo que me
reafirmo también con él dijo el concepto
gratis y el concepto fácil cuando
alguien nos dice esto es muy fácil o
esto es gratis es totalmente mentira o
no merece la pena hacerlo con lo cual os
invito a eludir lo gratis y lo fácil
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]